this is so ridiculous yet another person
claiming its racist to have a white
Santa you know and by the way for all
you kids watching at home
Santa just is white Jesus it was a white
man - and you heard her she said it
megyn kelly Jesus not only is Jesus
white but Santa is white so we have to
bring a former Christian white Irish
Englishman and get this a former
believer in Santa - to clear up this
topic here on the D show we'll be right
back
with you how are you brother John
Fontaine yep how are you you heard the
clip we're gonna play it again megyn
kelly yes we're gonna go to this clip
right now and by the way for all you
kids watching at home
Santa just is white Jesus it was a white
man - so you heard it say it and you
heard me up in the show I had to bring a
former Christian and white Irish British
English yes
in the former believer in Santa yes to
help us cover this topic yes so what do
you think about what she said well it's
um it's a fictional character you know
no one's actually seen the real front
father Christmas in England we call him
father Christmas I know you call him
sons all right yes so um yeah it's
fictional you know this is a few people
in history which is based on we've got
Saint Nicholas I was a Christian Bishop
in the area of Turkey which we know
today as Turkey and st. Nicholas was a
was from that part of the world at the
Mediterranean and he he wouldn't have
been white you know this area
certainly certainly wouldn't have in my
complexion mm-hmm which I would regard
as white so I don't know where she would
get this idea that Santa is white but
it's fictional you know the fact is they
arguing over a fictional character
doesn't exist so you can make him he can
be black if you believe in him he can be
Chinese doesn't matter because he's fake
it's fake
yeah but st. Nicholas by the way let's
go to this clip there's some forensic
evidence that also shows that he wasn't
white
Nicholas was from a part of the world
there's now Turkey and according to
forensic scientists who studied research
originally commissioned by the Vatican
he probably looked something like this
so in his clip that we just saw it
obviously shows him being someone from
the Mediterranean region there someone
like those yes somebody would maybe have
darker skin ya know to cope with the Sun
and things like that but yeah he's not
white yeah but I mean I mean Saint
Nicholas himself he's a historical
figure he actually took part in the
Council of Nicaea 325 AD which is
actually the Council which decided that
Jesus was a part of God so it's a very
important council are very important for
the history of Christianity yeah so
we'll get to Jesus in a minute let's
still you grow up you grew up tell us
all about as you grew up believing in
Santa Claus that you know the big fat
man was gonna come down to the gym leave
his reindeer up on the on the roof and
come bring your presents yeah we used to
believe this uh my family taught me that
father Christmas of real father
Christmas's come insit up come into our
school you know would sit on his knee he
would give us a present and ask us what
we wanted and and we would and we
believed in father Christmas you know it
was a reality
he was real and when we told that he's
not real it's a big shock to the system
you know it is a moment in our life when
we remember exactly where we was at the
time you you mentioned something that
you at one point you're live you thought
he was racist
yeah I mean I used to think father
Christmas or Santa was racist because
after the holidays I'll go into school
and my Pakistani friend didn't have any
presents you know so by the Christmas he
missed out all the Pakistanis all the
Africans you know he seemed the only
white people got gifts yeah that's
really interesting we got a clip over
here we're gonna go to that actually uh
Jesus he I mean that Jesus peace be upon
him but a Santa he's also been locked up
a few times if toys electronics
everywhere but everything in that bag is
hot it's larceny criminal trespass I
think we got enough why don't we just
head on downtown huh I'm gonna need it
oh he's running well so you can see
Santa here getting locked up you know
but also you you have in today's day and
age you have a lot of pedophiles you
have a saw I wouldn't really advise
would you you know letting your your
your child sit on some stranger's lap
especially in a sick society today that
we you know before these weirdos out
there yeah you don't know who he is so
how did you snap out of this I just yeah
I came to the conclusion that there's
something going on you know I mean I was
I can't remember how old I was but I was
questioning my mother I'm saying is he
real is he not real and eventually she
told me that it was not real mm-hmm
you know and yes big shock big shark but
it it makes me wonder why we teach our
children this you know why would we lie
to our children because it's um it's not
a good thing to do it teaches you that
you can't trust your own parents and if
I can't trust my own parents who can I
trust
mhm yeah people see it as a bit of fun
but in reality it's not really helping
but isn't it I mean you were a former
Christian mhm
and any believing Bible Bible believing
Christian if he looks into his Bible the
opposite is told about Christmas that
you shouldn't because when we look at
the roots of Christian of Christmas we
see that these have pagan origins yes so
the Bible says don't follow pagan
cultures hmm and actually you know it's
severe against it that God will punish
you yes did you know about that yeah I
mean all the prophets were sent
throughout time to correct the mistakes
which their people was making you know
because their people was following you
know customs which were not a part of
the true religion such as Abraham peace
be upon him he was correcting the
mistakes of his forefathers and the
pagan religions which they were
following and the same thing with with
Jesus peace be upon him you know he was
correcting the mistakes of his people
and this is the thing we shouldn't be
following
pagan origins I mean if we look at
Christmas these many origins you know
such as Mithra may throw as a Sun God
which was it was born on the 25th of
December you know this this Sun God died
was crucified was was three days later
came back to life it's the same story as
what we're hearing with it with with the
origins of Christmas
you know the 25th of December you know I
mean even called into the Bible and the
Quran Jesus peace be upon him could not
have been born around the time of
December all the time when they're
declaring I'll suggest that he was born
it would have been most probably in the
summer time do you really think now
Jesus would if he was alive today a
would he be celebrating Christmas would
he condemned it condone it what would be
his attitude to a lot of the things that
are attributed to him in today's time
yeah I mean we can see many traditions
are formed from from supposedly Jesus's
birthday but we should look at the look
at the teachings of Jesus himself you
know he never told us to celebrate his
his birthday this was not something that
we was told to do and we should and more
importantly we should he would never
told us to take him as God
you know this is this is that this is
the new thing people taking Jesus as the
Son of God our God himself
you know we should we should follow the
teachings of Jesus where Jesus says
worship the one creator you know this is
this is the message we should be we
should be following yeah if you stem now
if you look at his teachings like you're
saying so these holidays obviously are
have pagan origins was he even born on
wood can you say that he was born on
this day to 25th certainly not he wasn't
born on this day we can see from the as
I said from the Quran and the Bible we
can see that he was most likely born in
the summer time with a lot of evidence
to show that he was born within the
sonnet summer time so I mean you you
would say we almost before we go to
break that a lot of these lies they end
up catching up to you because this is
what atheists they take this you know
and they come from Christian backgrounds
and they see a lot of these things that
just don't make sense
you know lies after lies and then they
end up you know leaving these man-made
religions yeah I mean this is the thing
what's happened especially in in Britain
as well many people have left religion
altogether because they can see the
problems with the Bible and the Bible
doesn't make sense they can see the
Bible is not from the Creator
therefore they leave religion altogether
and this is why in Islam we have to try
and help people come back to the correct
religion which is Islam an essentially
think that what we have is is something
that's pointing us to asking for
evidence when we look at the evidence we
see that no way that the creator
sanction is is not from any of his
prophets including Jesus who we love and
revere as one of the mightiest messages
that God sent so we'll be right back
with more we have the next statement by
megyn kelly that we want to clarify and
hopefully she's tuning in and she can
get to benefit and because we're really
not trying to bash her at all we're just
trying to clear up and bring to light
some of these facts not fiction so we
cleared up if Jesus or Santa was white
yes and who he was fiction fiction
fiction and then we're also and most
people obviously know this but then
we're gonna get into Jesus she made a
bold statement tell him on that he was
white yeah and we're gonna talk about
his true mission mm-hmm when we come
back with the author of Jesus and the
injeel' John Fontaine here in the detail
we'll be right back
to save one life is as if you've saved
all humanity show kindness to your
parents just as they cared for you when
you were young give in charity of the
good things you earn even a smile is a
charity Explorer the real values of
Islam find the missing piece call us
toll-free at 877 why Islam back here on
the Deen show with author of Jesus in
the injeel john fontaine former believer
in santa yes
not anymore not anymore alright let's go
back to the unfortunate let's go to that
did it could begin Jesus it was a white
man to Jesus is a white man to what do
you got to say about that well Jesus was
from the children of Israel is that
correct yes of course I mean we we all
accept that you know Jews Christians and
Muslims accept that Jesus was from the
children of Israel so he would have been
from the part of the world in the Middle
East we say that he's bombing born in
Bethlehem and he was from the Middle
East
you know Bethlehem so we most likely
again not white like me well funny
enough we see the Christian is the way
they paint Jesus and draw Jesus he would
usually look something like me you would
have mostly maybe red hair red beard and
a thought you know he would look like a
Muslim so yeah so Jesus was what in
reality was from the Middle East he was
he was not white in the sense of the way
I'm white he was not European
he was from the Middle East and that
becomes a big problem when you give the
attributes of the crater to the
attributes of the human being and then
you give them a color skin tone yeah a
nationality a language so now people
start now the race Wars begin because
now you have the African Americans who
are making Jesus being black the
Hispanics got hey-zeus got a picture of
him and now it becomes a race problem
you know yeah and this isn't they've not
only done this with Jesus they've also
done this with God if you go to Italy
you look on the walls you know God is
also a white man you know he looks
Italian yeah you know taught you have to
you know there was appealing to the
audience if you like the the Italian
stallion if you like you know he's a he
he would look similar to Sylvester
Stallone yeah you know he's quite so so
well if you go to Africa these parts of
Africa where Jesus you see on the
churches I've seen myself that Jesus and
the angels are carved into the into
stone they look black yeah this is where
where this is in Senegal you know parts
of Senegal Sierra Leone yeah you know
the portray Jesus is black uh-huh so I
mean it's it's about people trying to
fit in and trying to fit their beliefs
within what they feel comfortable and
they probably both of them that end up
Santa Claus and Jesus if they were
trying to fly nowadays they probably end
up on a no-fly list yeah it's true yeah
isn't it true I mean generally you know
we don't get uneasy you don't go through
yet the airport sees yeah okay so moving
along I mean I think now that we've
cleared up okay
the doubts about that that obviously
Santa and this is that time of Christmas
we see that there was no sanction for it
in the Bible Jesus never taught it nor
was he born on that day now the message
I think this is even more important
because we have a lot of fictional
characters and a fictional events
they're just made up and suited for the
times and a lot of this make-believe
is just going on and on and people are
just getting fed up and like you
mentioned earlier you know the the 8th
the people are leaving religion and now
here comes Islam telling the truth and
what was the true message of Jesus you
know what what did he actually proclaim
did he proclaimed to be God it's law
clearly says no let's elaborate on this
and truly letting the people know that
this what we're gonna say right now this
is not fiction this is fact yeah the
true message of Jesus peace be upon him
what was that yeah that it's the thing
when Islam came it came with the the
final revelation which is the Quran
which is a perfect guidance for which we
use in our daily life you know it's not
just a law but its teachings within
which we would say use it as an example
not only the Quran but also the the
Prophet peace be upon him Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him we used the
example of his life in our daily life
and when we look into the Dupre the
previous if we look into other holy
books which claim to be holy books such
as the bible we see that there's a lack
of teachings within the New Testament
especially I was in the Christianity
which actually which actually lead
Christians to actually now look in other
in other directions for teachings for
direction in life as well so when we
look at the Quran I see the final
revelation and it is from the creator
and the Quran talks about the previous
prophets it talks about Jesus in depth
it talks about how he was he was born
there's a whole chapter named after his
mother Mary the surah Maryam which talks
about the birth of Jesus and also saw
Imran goes through the the family of
Jesus as well and we can see that Jesus
peace be upon him he came with the same
message as all the prophets which was to
worship the one creator the one God and
the way we do that is that we have the
five pillars of Islam the first form of
worship is to acknowledge your Creator
okay this the first thing we have to do
is acknowledge that there is a creator
and the only the Creator is worthy of
worship and this is this is the this is
the first
of Islam so once people understand that
and they can move on to the rest but
yeah so we stick to that first that
acknowledging that Jesus peace be upon
him was the Paragon example of human
excellence yes the best of character a
teacher just like Abraham Moses is
teaching the message that was sent by
the Creator for Humanity yes but now
people get confused because you asked
someone do you believe Jesus is his God
was he sent by God and most people agree
yeah he was sent by that but he's the
son of God yes so they attribute God
having a son yeah and then being one
yeah how do you clear this confusion I
mean we look at when we say the son of
God Jesus I mean we don't buzz --lens we
don't believe that Jesus is a physical
son of God now if you're talking about
metaphorical we can see that
metaphorically were all children of God
okay
David in the Bible is described disease
as a son of God but the Jews and the
Christians have never said that he's a
physical son of God you see so we can
see even within the Bible that is
metaphorical okay so Jesus yeah as a
metaphorically son of God but according
to Islam God does not have children okay
God is not like the creation we can't
imagine the crater is beyond our
comprehension okay
so Jesus is a prophet of God he's one of
the mightiest messages of God he came
with the teachings and we followed Jesus
we love Jesus as a Muslim we have to
love Jesus if we don't love Jesus and we
don't believe in Jesus as a prophet
we can't be Muslim okay because this is
one of the articles of faith as a Muslim
to believe in all the previous prophets
now if you ask obviously Jesus peace be
upon him he did he didn't speak Greek
he's big English he spoke Aramaic and
you talk about this in your book Jesus
and injeel so jesus today if we we
mentioned a word that he's never heard
like for instance was jesus a human was
Jesus a human I think everybody who
knows English would say yes yes correct
but now we're going to use a word that
sums up what he did his whole mission
and that word is Islam and Muslim can we
link that back you know Jesus that Jesus
was a Muslim who did Islam and now
connect it all together because many
people have the Miss know
that Islam is some new religion yes this
is something new that came along
Christianity came way before but you
know when we explained to him that no
Islam's been there from the beginning
Jesus was a Muslim but now there's some
confusion like how was that can you yeah
answer this I mean people always say I
hear this all the time you know they say
Oh Islam came later no it's the first
prophet in Islam is Adam peace be upon
him
you know prophet Adam and and Jesus and
all the prophets were worshipping the
one creator if we look at Abraham peace
be upon him he was not Jewish or
Christian and no Jew or Christian will
tell you that Abraham is Jewish okay
Abraham was a monotheists
he was submitting to the one creator the
one true God as according to the what he
had been revealed and the Arabic word
for this is Muslim so someone who
submits to God is a Muslim okay so at
the time of Moses Moses peace be upon
him was a Muslim he was submitting to
God the one true God the creator of the
universe the same way Jesus peace be
upon him was submitting to the one true
God and the art the Arabic word for this
is Islam now you obviously being a
former Christian was in your your and
your studying that is fascinate you and
this is one of the things that led you
to Islam along with all the evidence not
blind just blindly jumping into because
you have to sacrifice a lot to leave you
know your parents religion to come over
to us no I'm just one of the things that
fascinated yeah I had many questions you
know I was asking the church I was
asking the people at the church and he
couldn't answer me he was just telling
me how faith of blind faith I couldn't
and what he dancers yeah and if you want
answers you have to go where they have
answers yeah and when I started to look
into Islam they had answers all the
answers you found every unseen
everything that made clear purpose of
life everything why you've been created
and where you going when you die
everything is there Quran is the perfect
revelation so the rest of time yeah yeah
are we want to swage any fear because
now we have some more questions because
of the skeptics might thinking terrorism
has suppression of women and megyn kelly
is probably tuned in she's like oh come
on what'd they do to their women right
yeah just hold on Meghan please we're
gonna address these issues with the
author of Jesus and the injeel here on
the Dean show gee
often mistranslated as holy war the word
jihad means to struggle Islam does not
preach violence it does not preach
vicious holy war it certainly does not
condone terror and suicide bombing Islam
preaches compassion tolerance and
justice find the truth about Islam call
toll-free 877 why Islam order your FREE
copy of the Quran today
back here on the Dean show and hopefully
our special guests tuning in megyn kelly
we got to clear this up for her and now
you've just expressed what Islam is
really about worshiping the Creator not
the creation and explain this confusion
about the literal meaning that God
actually had a son that doesn't make
sense you know and when you really think
about it how could you know it doesn't
make sense will you battle in with that
for some time and the whole idea of God
dying you know you got sending his His
only Son
why wasn't a daughter no one can explain
it but why I mean look if this is true
what I mean in this you know shouldn't
is the the women the feminist movement
jump up and say why winding god have a
daughter right yeah and then they come
together and have grandchildren yeah
doesn't make sense doesn't make sense I
mean it God created Adam yes so how can
God be Adam how can God how can God be a
part of the creation you know the
creates it can not be a part of the
creation you know it doesn't make sense
yeah it's I mean it when he starts a
question they they won't answer your
questions and then in the church yeah no
one has answers because there's no
answer you went through this - yeah
so megyn kelly now she's hopefully God
willing we want all of our viewers to
reach out to her and her Twitter and
send this to her and have her get
involved and really see what we're
coming from because there's a lot of
misconceptions but you got an American
and Irish English here and we're not
Arab because that's one of the things
people think okay you know you're you're
a Muslim so you're an Arab and we see
that obviously Jesus was not white he
was a Semitic so he spoke Aramaic sister
language - Arabic he called on God by
allah llahu right so this is amazing you
learned some very interesting amazing
facts but now someone's like look not
every how does the saying go not every
Muslim is a not every terrorist as a
Muslim but every Muslim is a terrorist
right yeah and people ask you so you
became a terror as soon as you tell him
now you became one who submitted to the
will of the creator you're a terrorist
now
yeah so what do you say to sway Jenny
fear so you know people are really
having some bizarre crazy things
associated with slum
well many times people judge Islam or
they just Islam by the people by the
followers and that's not correct
you wouldn't judge a car by the driver
would you know you know you would judge
the car by the instruction manual which
is the Quran okay so we have to judge
Islam by the actual fundamental
principles of Islam if you go to the
Quran and the hadith the sayings of
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him we
can judge this land by this and when you
see this you see that Islam is perfect
and the funny thing is when you look on
online or you look into the media
whenever they attack Islam they attack
the Muslims okay they don't actually
attack the sources of Islam they don't
attack the Quran they don't attack the
hadith they attack the actual Muslims
but when you see people attacking
Christianity and they tend to look at
the contradictions in the Bible they
look at the problems of the actual sauce
if you understand where I'm coming from
because they see that the sauce has a
lot of problems but the thing with Islam
is the sauce is in Islam a perfect as I
said we have the original Quran less of
less a word for word it's the same Quran
which we recite every day which we had
at the time of Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him any contradictions in the crown
because people say okay look you know
something that was written that long
time ago these men were inspired they
wrote the Bible so even with all the
mistakes and contradictions I'm not
trying to disparage on anybody just
trying to bring just like we brought
Santa Claus to light you know the Tooth
Fairy wouldn't talk about him yeah but
you know now we're trying to bring this
to light the true message of Jesus peace
be upon him amen yeah I mean I'm the
thing with me I didn't just accept Islam
I tried to prove it wrong for many years
it may be two years I was I was trying
to prove Islam wrong I was going to to
the Quran to the hadith to try and find
something to prove to disprove Islam and
I couldn't find it eventually I had to
submit myself to so but do you think
before we leave we have to cut out
people have this illusion in their head
what
the truth is they want God to look like
this color like them speak this language
and now when the message doesn't fit
with what they wanted to be it becomes a
problem do you see what I'm saying yes
and now isn't this an obstacle for many
people's you have to humble yourself
it's not like what can God do for me
it's like what can I do for my Creator
yes so when the message comes now you
have to eliminate all of this racism all
this hate and block it out and really
just you know examine it humbly this is
a part of the submission
you know because everyone before Islam
your your ego is telling you that God
should be Y or God should be black no
God is something that you cannot
comprehend and once you understand this
then you can submit to God and you have
to think of it like this if the create
it if we look at the creation okay now
if we look into the heavens and the
earth and we look into the stars and and
and and the universe it's upon a life if
God created the universe surely this God
is worthy of worship yeah and we can't
see God we can't even look at the Sun if
we look at the Sun we go blind we can't
even imagine the next solar system in a
summer I'm coming from so how can we
imagine God how can we see God we can
it's beyond our comprehension yeah so
when once we understand that God has
created the universe this God is worthy
of worship and as I say that the the
first form of worship is acknowledging
your creator actually acknowledging that
he is there that there is a creator and
acknowledging that he's worthy of
worship and you do this by testifying in
and you make a statement you testified
the Shahada which is the declaration of
faith and you say that there's nothing
worthy of worship except Allah God and
that Muhammad peace be upon him is the
final messenger and once you accept this
you have come into the fold of Islam and
that's all it takes is so easy to become
a Muslim and this is the same I mean
declaration you'd make during damaji if
you were living during a time of deeds
it isn't during the time of Jesus
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the Creator and Jesus is the messenger
you're not the god or the Sun literal
son great so you start to connect this
to make sense so clean
terrorism with Islam baloney exactly
suppression of women doesn't have
baloney yeah so all these things people
if they really look at it I mean we're
not denying that that maybe some people
are oppressed by Muslims but Muslims are
not perfect okay but Islam is if this if
this is happening this is against Islam
yes definitely
so much to talk about go ahead just one
last thing the reason it's so important
to submit to your Creator okay because
it's easy to believe in the Creator when
we look into the into the proofs but you
have to submit okay Satan believes in
the Creator okay he believes it that the
Creator exists but it's not enough okay
you have to submit to the crater you
have to acknowledge that only the
Creator is worthy of worship give the
example that you gave about someone
denying their own mother yeah I mean if
I'm a good person I do the best amount
of good deeds in the world you know
accurate I can be Nelson Mandela okay
well if I ignore my own mother am i a
good person
no the it outweighs everything I do so
how can I be a good person a truly good
person if I don't acknowledge the
creator that's deep
yeah thank you very much we look we got
a still you know it's coming around that
time Christmas so we're thinking about
doing another show yeah you're gonna be
around yeah I'm around okay so God
willing we have you back again yeah okay
thank you very much thank you very much
for tuning in megyn kelly hopefully if
she hasn't washed or she's watching you
guys can reach out to her and get her
this show on her Twitter page
we'll have this on our Twitter page go
ahead and forward it to her and God
willing if she Tunes in you know because
there are a lot of misconceptions you
know when the truth comes you know she
was an attorney and she can understand
that you know attorneys job is to try to
if you're in this part of the law where
you're trying to discredit someone so an
old lady comes up very innocent but if
you're in opposition your job is to make
this lady looked out to be the liar so
now you have Islam coming and it's the
truth but it has all of these negative
connotations
is attributed to it but when you come to
to know it for what it is that its
simplicity
the believable message and then you as a
woman if megyn kelly you tuning in you
you start to see these facts that the
first person to embrace the submission
to the to the crater when it came to the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
during his time was a woman that's right
the the first person to die who was a
martyr defending Islam she stood for
Islam was a woman the greatest scholar
in Islam was a woman so talk to a Muslim
woman and see if she's subjugated or
oppressed because that's usually what
they'll bring up and then you see that
through watching the Deen show you see
that a lot of these lies that been told
to us the whole Santa Clause fable and
then you have the tooth fairy and then
Jesus his true message we've tried to
click we clear that up Jesus now never
claiming to be God or a literal son of
God so if you were lied to once you'd be
lied to twice but Islam sets it straight
and gives you the evidence and the proof
so you can go ahead and submit knowing
that indeed this is the way of life from
the crater that gives you peace
prosperity and purpose in this life and
paradise in the next definitely without
a doubt you'll come to know that if you
humbly seek the guidance from your maker
your Creator so hopefully this show has
been a benefit and during this time now
it's time for us to really reflect if
this was brought to your attention and
to go beyond just blindly following the
customs cultures of your grandparents
forefathers and be someone who is humbly
seeking to know really what's the
purpose of life why have I been created
and where am I going when I die tune in
every week to the Deen show follow us
we'll have this posted on our Facebook
and our Twitter and let's help get this
message to our hopefully our new fan of
the deed show megyn kelly we'll see you
next time until then peace be unto you